Snap is a camera company.
We feel like we're really at the beginning of what cameras can do.
Cameras have evolved from being just a piece of hardware like a chip...
...to software that's connected to the internet.
Before cameras were the best way to perfectly save...
...or record something that you saw and they sort of helped augment memory.
But now, you know, cameras augment the way that we talk.
You know, if you think about the keyboard...
...and the way that sort of became the primary input...
...for everything you do on your computer...
...you know everything starts with that flashing cursor.
With Snapchat, the camera has become the primary input for the phone.
Throughout history, people have wanted to communicate in intimate ways...
...whether it's the handwriting on a letter that reveals someone's personality...
...or the sound of their voice.
I can't imagine the way it must have felt on that first phone call...
...when you could hear the other person's voice in real time...
...coming through the phone, all that emotion.
I think Snapchat really tapped into that human desire to communicate...
...in a way that feels like it's face-to-face even if you're far away.
The first time you use it and you can see what someone else is seeing...
...at the same time, from their perspective.
That moment, it makes you feel close.